Another thing you might want to do at
this point is try to predict which
students are likely to pass their first
project, and which students aren't.
You could take a first pass of this
using some heuristics based on
your exploration.
For example,
you could predict that students who
spend more time in the classroom during
their first week are more likely to
eventually pass the first project.
However, getting a really good
prediction this way could be difficult.
For one thing, there are lots of
different pieces of information that we
probably should be looking at.
You'd probably at least want to look
at the things I looked at earlier,
lessons completed,
minutes spent, and days visited.
But there could be a lot more
pieces of information or
features that you'd like
to look at as well.
This wouldn't be so bad except that all
of your different features can have
complex interactions with each other.
For example, when you look at minutes
spent in the classroom on its own,
it might look like a really
important feature.
But then when you look
at lessons completed and
minutes spent together, you might see
that after you already know how many
lessons a student completed, knowing
how many minutes they spent doesn't
give you any additional information.
In many situations like this one,
you can use machine learning to make
pretty good predictions automatically,
usually a lot better than
the predictions you could make by hand.
Depending on the machine learning
algorithm you use, it might also give
you a ranked list of which features
were most important to the prediction,
which can be very interesting.
If you'd like to learn more about this,
you might want to take our
introduction to machine learning
course linked in the instructor notes.